HAPPEN.
>> JOHN ROBERTS, REPORTING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE INFORMATION
TONIGHT ABOUT COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN TWO KEY PLAYERS IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION
OF THE 2016 TRUMP CAMPAIGN, EVEN
AFTER THE ELECTION.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE REPORTS.
>> NINE DAYS AFTER THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE EXCHANGE
TAX THAT FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED
ARE UNDER NEW SCRUTINY REVIEWING
THE GENESIS OF THE FBI RUSSIA
PROBE.
A STRING OF TEXT REFERRED TO AN
EMAIL AND PRIOR WITH PENTZ.
PAGE WRITES, WOULD IT BE UNUSUAL
TO HAVE THEM SHOW UP AGAIN?
PETER STRZOK RESPONSE, OR HE'S
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE GUY,
SAYING IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE.
HE CAN ASSESS IF THERE ARE ANY
NEW QUESTIONS ARE DIFFERENT
DEMEANORS.
IF THE HUSBAND IS THERE HE CAN
SEE IF THERE ARE PEOPLE WE CAN
DEVELOP WITH POTENTIAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
A FORMER SPECIALISTS OF THE TEXT
APPEAR TO CONFLICT WITH STRICT
RULES MADE UP BY THEN FBI
DIRECTOR ROBERT MUELLER.
QUOTE, THESE TEXTS INDICATE BOTH
FBI EMPLOYEES WERE EXECUTING
INVESTIGATIVE STRATEGIES ON A
SENSITIVE INVESTIGATIVE MATTER.
WITHOUT ANY REGARD FOR THE
MUELLER ENDORSED A GUIDE.
WITH THE REPORT COMPLETE AND HE
MAY FIND HIMSELF BACK ON THE
HILL.
>> I'M CERTAIN THAT CONGRESS
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT ANY INVESTIGATION ONCE
IT'S CLOSED AND ASK ALL THESE
QUESTIONS, AND I WOULD LOVE TO
ANSWER EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
YOUR QUESTIONS.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL RECENTLY
TESTIFIED HE IS CONDUCTING A
REVIEW OF THE FBI PROBE ORIGINS
AND WHETHER SURVEILLANCE OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS BASED ON
SOUND INTELLIGENCE.
DEVON NUNEZ SAID, THIS IS MORE
EVIDENCE THAT THE FBI TRUNK
BRUSH INVESTIGATION WAS FILLED
WITH IRREGULARITIES.
>> THERE WAS NO IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE FROM LAWYERS FOR LISA
STRUCK LISA      LISA PAGE AND P
STRUCK LISA      LISA PAGE AND T
STRUCK LISA      LISA PAGE AND R